something that [ __ ]
Oh
what's up you bad [ __ ] I'm back
[ __ ] my nose a little [ __ ] up I got
some [ __ ] blood rocks in their mix
with some coke rocks and some [ __ ]
some stunts but I'll live the
antibiotics all right my wrist hurts the
[ __ ] oxycottons who eats those things
that'll do dick but listen enough with
the chitty-chat I've begun my little
brothers leave freshmen [ __ ]
kettlebells is [ __ ] we just went to the
weed snow we picked up a batch we [ __ ]
it it's in the car right now get dry and
ready understand me
I got a perennial joy one of the best as
usual I take the filter off because this
is the Gentiles only flop The [ __ ]
spoke with these filters to be cool look
at me I got a filter I always tear it
off that's the [ __ ] amateurs
I'm back [ __ ] understand me stitches
two straws at my nose
they don't [ __ ] matter
I missed you [ __ ] look at ya
looks like you put two dicks in there
look how big they made the [ __ ] holes
I was like Michael Jackson's before the
[ __ ] before he left but who gives a
[ __ ] we're back and it's a beautiful day
to be alive the sun's out the birds are
chirpin and that's it I missed you
[ __ ] you know that right
you guys are my fucked-up world without
you I got no guts
I'm still not RG % I'm still coochie-coo
sorry I gotta take a nap
I got snapchat my nose blood snots
everything but I miss you
nothing wrong with that I get some
protein with me today a nice little
[ __ ] soup my wife made a nice fish
soup with crabs scallops and shrimp and
potatoes we think you're dealing with
[ __ ] joy bananas
not my smoking reefer and aborted don't
get me wrong I've been smoking since
4:30 since I got up but we came over
after kettlebells we've been a little
mission I can't drive again and here we
are doing our [ __ ] thing making it
happen [ __ ] you understand me I
suggest you do the same look at this
[ __ ] do I got some blue cookies for
you that is so [ __ ] good
oh it is so [ __ ] good there's blue
cookies it's in the car right now trying
we're gonna bust it out I'm the bomb is
that tonight I can't take no [ __ ] no
wake and bake them announces 4:30 I've
been waking up bacon since 5:00 to 4:30
but it don't matter
like eight million like dried leaves
over there you throw that
yeah that's what we do
subway 10:30 we just thought was
something kill you
I'll give knowledge we go do it's that
type of warning we got look at this
oh yeah oh yeah and as usual take the
filter off this pcs I'm not gonna cook
it up that was that was a join the debt
look at this turning purple already
that's why I take the filter off
uh-huh that's it people
next week up a flap this Thursday night
I'm gonna start my [ __ ] hour run when
you beat you can critique you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you can beat
me up I don't give a [ __ ]
we put you before I'm happy you guys
maybe hold on to this operation see
usually without you guys I would have
said it in [ __ ] canceled it cuz I'm a
[ __ ] half a [ __ ] but now that I got
you guys holding my feet to the fire I
can't [ __ ] up
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I've done it
before I left the hospital once before I
just took the [ __ ] out of my office said
abandon ship no yes I didn't gave the
black guy 50 bucks he [ __ ] walk me to
my car yes he could ask my wife when I
got the surgery last night yes I did
that is snort coke for like [ __ ] four
days so I couldn't sit no recovery room
I had to go pick up a package check the
surgery was done I was 11 aboard and I
was getting let loose to go snort some
coke that's how much of a [ __ ] feat
that was but that was then and this is
them understand me capiche [ __ ]
that's why if you do a drug stop there's
a whole [ __ ] world out there it
really is when you do with drugs you did
this a whole other world out there but
would you stop doing drugs you realize
this whole [ __ ] world I did a week
feet
I believe those oxycottons you know I'll
tell you what
David worse didn't blow their [ __ ]
terrible of snakes terribly
they make Ida scratching my ass all
night and [ __ ] my legs
who needs that [ __ ] they're like this is
it this is all you need reef up like up
[ __ ] you understand me
won't a clean style smoking joints out
everywhere nobody goes to jail nobody
gets their feelings hurt
take this take this off
make a whole new situation see the pulse
right there for the [ __ ] THC she was
smoking it
I love this smoking outside being free
everybody wants to jump up and down and
go to the mosh pit and ain't be gray it
this is my [ __ ] mosh pit of death no
protest black lies [ __ ] the matter you
know what do you do
can you take this was gonna happen how
much lovely thing to shoot people and do
this [ __ ] the media blows it up you know
three [ __ ] get hit by a car you know
you're nothing about it I'm like don't
get shot in the head
they got y'all from speed down that's
the way life is
just don't be a shuffling I said mind
your business thing
ain't nobody gonna shoot me of my little
Bobby I'm saying they come over here
shoot
I totally join I run in the will get the
pipe guys I got one last there's seeds
of this last [ __ ] weed that's gonna
kill me that's how I roll people we go
24/7 just kill Lee
I'm back like herpes I got all my
weapons out
I got bazookas I got everything he
whacks
let's kill this soldier this is the
bottom half of this you have no idea
this has been marinated for a week then
now I'm going to open that up and put
this in the end
look at that perfect the bulldog
now we take this roach and we open this
deadly [ __ ] stink of death up then
you put the remainder in there with the
[ __ ] top oh my god which is why
that's 10:30 10:30 this is when we get
[ __ ] wolf dub intente [ __ ]
stitches and everything when they take
the stitches out of my nose smokes gonna
come up to tell Emily no it's for the
guys next to you yes for you cuz this
[ __ ] guy tries to blame you
you think hair scopes up let's go
Oh what do you mean that's not exam you
know you do the [ __ ] big you gotta be
training he just left kettlebells your
lungs a stretch I just love your [ __ ]
on the mommy of debt
[Music]
so it's all about just Wednesday baby
boys I can't do dick the auntie Miley's
got me a little [ __ ] up I can't really
breathe from write jokes to get ready
that's it that's all I got
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight at
eight o'clock I'm happy and you too then
I miss you [ __ ] the bot of my
heart
I was a dual periscope yesterday but I
was still bleeding every time I took a
hit a little smarter four red came on I
didn't want to [ __ ] with you guys like
and that's it that's it that's that it's
a beautiful day by the balls again
getting shot at and your uncle Joey's
back like [ __ ] you know I've seen you
[ __ ] 8 o'clock tonight and stay
black oh you poor life be nothing throw
our our I love you guys thank you for
the well-wishes
thank you for taking of me thank you for
the compliment everything I love you
Greg and limp hours in the [ __ ] house
I love you guys Greg Lynn I call you
later [ __ ] stay black uncle Joey
gotcha please over here mummified